you mentioned john wick and john wick
obviously incredibly
uh not realistic but say a guy like jon
jones
say he gets into a fight with four
regular dudes does he beat four regular
dudes 110
yeah really four regulated in under a
minute probably yeah
so how many regular dudes are we talking
about you need to take
jon jones ten how big are they how about
these regular dudes
say do they have any training or just no
no training okay
zero training yes they're all zero
because just because he hits one punch
and done kind of he just knows too much
[ __ ] and he's
leverage and then he's gonna be backing
up starching dudes then when they get
close
he's [ __ ] hip tossing them for real
taking into cars i think
yeah and and he's crazy his
understanding of distance and like his
awareness around him and then also
um a guy like john jones who has been
not only is so excessively talented
but has been through so many battles a
regular human is gonna
maybe get to while he's looking at
another fighter he's gonna crack him and
he's gonna be like
you know what i'm saying also that first
guy looping punch he's gonna be like
like [ __ ] toby maguire and spiderman
spiderman
[Music]
john's understanding of leverage and
everything he'd be so silly he would
just
take someone down so easily he's going
to use your body like like a battering
ram like num chucks that is
so he's going to pick me up and swing me
around that guy's big dick and he's
going to throw him like
10 for real i've always wondered because
i know those jobs for john johnson
and and he's but on the high end say a
dude like you
you're a trained guy you're pretty big
normal
people how many normally yeah say
four it's so if john's ten i'm four i'm
like the nicotine patch i'm a four year
four john's a thought
if you've if you've i i've had the
luxury and i i'm shitty but i've had the
luxury of
sparring with professional boxers and
muay thai fighters and i've had the
immense luxury of grappling with some of
the best in the world
it's you can't explain how [ __ ]
helpless you are if you're it's not
really because it's
insane it's an it's a different it'd be
like it's insane
it's insane i i'm i'm john's at least
ten i'm gonna see
i can pick up chrome gracie like this
and deadlift him
for 40 reps and when i roll jiu jitsu
the three or four times when i roll with
crone
he he's like literally expends no energy
when it it he decides do he plays with
me and then he decides
we'll talk about this when jason ellis
comes on the show and we have jason on
when i first met jason i was a late
replacement someone's supposed to be
there my publicist calls me goes hey we
need you to fill in
i don't know jason at all i know i walk
in my car he has tattoo on his head
whatever
we sit down and he he didn't like
whatever we hated each other for
whatever he hate
and he's being like mean he's like oh
what's it like to get knocked out but
i'm like what the [ __ ] going on this
dude
and then he starts talking [ __ ] about
jiu jitsu at the time because he didn't
know anything about it he goes
dude justin's kind of gay that's what
you do i'm like he was i don't think it
works and you'll see i don't think it
works i'm like
alright dude i guarantee it works i
could choke out everybody in this room
in under a minute he goes no you can't
go someone said and i'm heeded that time
i'm just a straight ufc fighter
i just moved to l.a i'm like set a timer
i will [ __ ] up everybody
are you your size like were you bigger
at the time um 240
240 and like but in shape 240
yeah i mean yeah
i mean but this is even this is even
different this is just
he was doing jiu jitsu and wearing this
dude we're at this little studio in
hollywood when this happened
and i go everybody in this room i would
choke out under a minute and he said a
time and i [ __ ] up everybody
in under a minute come on and the last
guy was like his little sound guys
good night i was like what's the time
he's like 57 seconds like yes
but when i get off stage at the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just read a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
[Laughter]
dude grab that mic son